[Musique]
coucou c'est moi la surprise on va
commencer par une petite méditation pour
se reconnecter à la source
vous allez prendre une grande
inspiration fermer les yeux reconnecter
vous la source
ouvrez les yeux vous l'avez senti très
puissant a oui ça permet de synchroniser
la la vibration de notre aura et de nos
chakras avec la fréquence de la terre et
c'est pas notre expert sur le
réchauffement climatique qui me dira le
contraire
alors qui suis-je
vous demandez-vous d'envoi t3 de tête je
suis ginette guinette pour les intimes
jean est pour les gens qui viennent de
la halle outre atlantique comme hello
and spirits
je suis également entrepreneuse j'ai une
start up en tant que médium karmique
transgénérationnel intégrative mais pas
que je suis également chaman quantique
c'est très rare et c'est donc un immense
honneur pour vous de m'avoir ce soir
bon comme vous j'ai écouté les petits
speaker ça qui nous ont si vous voulez
des livres réduit du mieux qu'ils ont pu
oui non je salue leur vaillance mais moi
je vous cache pas que je n'ai pas appris
grand chose
non parce que bon alors tout ce qui
concerne l'univers pour moi déjà je suis
astrologue également je vous ai pas dit
donc que moi les planètes il voulait me
parle directement général et puis en
plus moi j'ai déjà visité mars
bah oui en voyage astral sais pas ce que
c'est que voyez astral photo lors dire
c'est quand l'esprit si vous voulez se
dissocie du corps etc vadeleux delà des
limites habituelles de l'espace et du
temps c'est quand même pas compliqué je
pense qu'on pourrait conseiller ce genre
de technique à notre explorateur parce
que pour le pôle nord par exemple y est
on est de subir les vous a vu six
orteils non plus tout ce qui est santé
holistique et que moi le coaching aussi
je connais j'ai fait une formation de
coaching sur groupon
c'est là qu'en s'est rencontré avec sept
autres moulins depuis j'ai été certifié
koch professionnels baptisé kin est donc
oui donc je vous disais les les comment
dire l'histoire de santé holistique où
je suis j'ai aussi étudié bien
évidemment lomé plastie un métier
pékinoise bon beaucoup de choses mais si
vous voulez plus d'informations vous
aurez tout sur mes blogs chaîne youtube
il ya aussi des possibilités
je fais un appel aux dons pour mon orgue
et ginette sur la planète alors en
revanche moi je ne reçois que les
bitcoins bah oui on en 2019
ne me dites pas que vous êtes encore 12
euros là à berne et en province par
tomber donc pourquoi suis-je là vous
demandez vous oui parce que j'ai aussi
un danger lit dans les pensées je suit
et les
deux missions pour moi ce soir c'est
aujourd'hui fois depuis hier parce qu'on
est arrivé hier il fallait bien tu
travailles tout ça oui
la première mission soutient énergétique
and speak earth vous les auriez vu avant
de monter sur scène ils étaient stressés
mon dieu ce traité stressés ils avaient
les petites jambes qui tremblaient
craint donc moi avec tout le talent et
la générosité
je leur ai proposé pour les détendre une
séance de réflexologie annales ils ont
pas voulu
donc on a basculé sur une pratique plus
courante de réflexologie nasale ça
débouche au sien
à vous rigolez parce que la deuxième
mission c'est pour vous et voilà ça va
bientôt commencer
ça c'était l'introduction oui parce que
j'ai un secret pour vous tout ce que
vous avez entendu ce soir
si vous avez suivi du début à la fin
parce que j'en ai vu quelques uns qui
ont un peu bon oui j'ai un don de
l'omnipotence également un jeu je vois
tout je suis un peu partout tout ce que
vous avez entendu tous ces messages
un portois quand même ne sont pas c'est
que dans vos esprits conscient et grâce
à moi on va le faire passer au niveau du
subconscient le subconscient c est en
dessous du temps science est un peu plus
comment on va faire une séance d'hypnose
deux groupes ça rigole mois là
donc non c'est très simple vous laisser
quitter par me voir pour mobilis et à
l'oeil et au doigt donc ils vont vous
installez d'abord d'une manière bien
confortable je vais faire la même chose
parce que c'est très important le
confort du corps travaille on travaille
on ne sent pas petit donc on va je vais
rentrer en france pour pouvoir mieux
vous guider
je rentre en transes mettez vos deux
pieds bien à plat sur le sol
[Musique]
maintenant vous allez tous se mettre au
boulot monstre la tête en chapeaux
pointus comme ceci
à lasser assez bien
et puis vous allez tendres nous demain
devant roux comme cela ils croisent et
omar voilà ça c'est bien appuyé
maintenant vos deux mains comme ça
devant notre visage et vous fait
d'écarter vos deux environ 3
alors ensuite focalisé sur un an qui se
situe entre vos deux doyens écoute de ma
voix vous doivent se rapprocher quand
même attiré il résiste pas à tirer vers
l'un vers l'autre et je vais compter
2000 jusqu'à moi mines et lorsque vous
entendrez le point mi hauteur mieux
alors avec le mur l'inconscient de tris
tu présentes dans ce territoire avec le
999 déjà en train de vous demander
comment nous allons arriver jusqu'au 20
mai
avec 1998 de plus en plus rare lâcher de
plus en plus relax et avec le set sans
doute juste un timing à respecter plus
que c'est relâche de plus en plus de
vieux
euh courante de 3,2 de la cheville de se
faire maintenant
[Musique]
et vous allez faire apparaître sur
l'écran de votre confiance votre enfant
intérieur non devait pas vraiment enfin
intérieur de vous sauf si vous êtes
enceinte que vous êtes en fente ofaj
maîtrise fait apparaître cet enfant
intérieur cette partie de vous peut-être
que vous étiez vulnérables ont l'air
d'innocence votre you feel bad
[Musique]
et vous allez lui dire quelques petits
secrets quelques petites vérités mais
cédric ya quand même des vérités premier
secret de poireaux et les kinés nom
jésus n'est pas vraiment le fils de dieu
par contre ne lui dites pas que son vrai
père est un violeur pédophile de le
choquer
deuxième secret
oui les fleurs du bien c'est très bien
c'est mieux que les fleurs du mal parce
que le bien c'est toujours mieux que le
mal ça sent meilleur et ça pique mans
s'il ne comprend pas celui secret vous
lui direz qu'il regardera sur youtube
près parce que c'est le titre de la
soirée global perdu le troisième secret
oui c'est vrai la planète se réjouit
enfin va pas se mentir pour faire tout
ce que tu as vu ce qu'il va de 7 degrés
à biarritz ou en février personne ne le
fera sans moi
[Musique]
le quatrième ce cri vous allez lui faire
un petit mensonge on ment toujours
kippen aux enfants regardez ce qui se
passe avec le père noël au team
[Musique]
le petit mensonge oui les hommes les
femmes ceux qui sont implantés les deux
sont égaux très inégaux même surtout les
hommes blancs beaucoup de filles elle le
prend dans vos bras
je sais pas déjà fait et on va compter 2
0 jusqu'à moi 1000 et tandis que voulait
percer ça va s'intégrer au plus profond
de tremblay être dangereux par celle de
chaque cellule de 5 à taux de confiance
qui a été dit est codé voulu verser plus
de chanter une petite chansonnette
bravo monsieur le monde 2 chapeau
monsieur le monde même quand les gens
diront que vous ne tournez pas toujours
très rond vous raconter de moins 1000
jusqu'à 0 en prenant votre temps mais
pas trop quand même parce qu'on a un
buffet qui nous attend derrière et vous
pouvez les yeux pour ceux qui n'ont pas
déjà rouvert à très haut débit 100
bonsoir je m'appelle benjamin merial
j'ai 36 ans et des poussières
je suis forme hypnothérapeute formateur
également comédien dans mon temps libre
diagnostiqué récemment schizophrène
mais j'ai bien écouté un priori il faut
pas trop prendre les choses au sérieux
et quand j'étais petit j'étais un gamin
assez marrant j'étais efféminé moi je
joue avec les filles j'adorais les
poupées je commandais des barbie pour
noël je mettais les talons de ma mère je
me maquille et je veux coiffure et en
grandissant j'ai peu à peu senti ce que
j'identifie maintenant comme un
sentiment de honte vous en doutez ce
n'est pas forcément ce qu'on attend d'un
petit garçon avec l'adolescence c'est
l'arrivée à l'âge adulte cette partie de
moi s'est peu à peu éteinte
un jour lors d'une séance de
psychothérapie
j'ai reconnecter avec cet enfant que
j'étais par le souvenir et ça l'a
ressuscité donner un petit échantillon
ce soir alors si vous aussi un jour vous
avez le privilège de rencontrer cette
partie de vous dans un contexte peut
être un peu plus émotionnelle un peu
plus intime
dites lui s'il vous plaît qu'il ou elle
est libre d'exprimer sa vraie nature
qu'elles soient complexes qu'elles
soient étonnante surprenant et original
paradoxal et promettez lui que quelles
que soient les turbulences que la vie
mettra sur son chemin vous ne
l'abandonnerait jamais s'il vous plaît
promettez vous que vous ne vous
abandonnerai jamais bravo monsieur le
monde
bravo pour la colombe
si vous lui il est c'est la vie nous
vous dirons simplement merci
[Musique]
c'était un immense honneur pour moi
d'être avec vous ce soir
merci
[Applaudissements]
c'est une plume voir son territoire